hey guys so we're hanging out in my
kitchen I'm here with Josh Sundquist
what's up we're hanging out some time we
are and I just seens kitchen yeah oh we
should've all wait hold on
so we asked you guys on Twitter what we
should bake and it's just the craziest
thing somebody suggested that we should
think kick decorate it like your book
since we happen to have red black and
white icing which happen to be the
colors of my book you have the
directions also I should note that um
Josh does not eat gluten so guess what
we have and I just want to also want to
know I'm not like one of the trendy I
don't eat gluten people I actually have
celiac disease it's a real thing people
three cups of gluten-free multi-purpose
flour oh we go to the cupcake mixture
what's that one okay so now we need 1
and 3/4 cup okay I think that's er so
you have 2 cameras here so we can play
both of them awesome
let's get you something else we don't
like the measure here this is also for
liquid measuring it's a really precise
amount little thing just put it in wrong
it's great okay so this is not a point
in the blender like you do with blunders
this is how we do also something else
that I learned about gluten-free flour
I forgot what did you say yeah if you're
equipping gluten-free you really need
the xanthan gum if you don't it all
falls apart I've learned this not by
cooking myself because of course I don't
cook but because actually tried to cook
something for me once and didn't put it
in and it was all like crumbly it was it
was not even like a real thing so this
is the thing oh we don't need to need it
after I made that whole big speech
really quick let's just put a little bit
in how is that possible I put some in
it's okay we used it usually you only
put in
a teaspoon but I call those tips here
Jim milk I know
good surprising this is what we like to
use our our thing called judgment half
cup I see why while your recipes turned
out so well okay this ring busy cooking
stuff yeah oh no no we need a cup of
sugar is it named for sugar here yeah
yeah this is good to be many really
sweet that's like almost as much do it
oh yeah priceless so when you said of
cups are different for powders versus
liquids yep that's so confusing it's
essentially yeah so shape up more
anything look honey I'm smelling this is
Molly's mind it doesn't smell like
anything what do you what do you guys
call tablespoon Roger Dibble hmm this is
imitation rum extract perfect how much
of this piss - tips - tips yeah they
look good about that because just saw
really small right well yeah I like nala
okay we're gonna need 1/2 a cup of soft
butter just do something like you leave
it out for a while but no you just put
it the microwave okay jesso name for
butter around there yeah hearted and how
juice no you can go whatever you wanna
make up a name yes well that is
softening we could add 3 large eggs or
as we like to call them
chicken periods goodra Portugal yeah I
didn't know that you have been in but
that's really good that's what yeah Wow
do you just crack them into this yeah
but no shells should I try to juggle
these do you have to do juggling skills
we're gonna find out
holy crap it's boiling afraid that once
I start juggling these I'm not gonna be
able to stop okay but like because
you're just that good at juggling no I
know I said that was like the biggest
humble right here's the problem when I
juggle
I just keep juggling forever it's I
can't like I just it's impossible for me
to make mistakes so I usually just don't
start in the first place well like you
might stop I have to catch them all
separately so they don't hit each
other's is it really all about are you
good at juggling yeah like can you you
can do this oh god oh god I'm so nervous
we don't go casual yet this is amazing
yeah I can see what the hell this is a
problem for you you just can't stop so
if I throw one up yeah you catch it
yeah just like you yell or something
ah ba books no H were broken this is
great it's really disappointing so guess
what
Wow though it's really not really much
good chuckling yeah you're like serious
about your skills which was broken on
purpose service okay let's go good
directions preheat the oven
Oh to 350 degrees but do I need more of
something I feel like I'm like mm-hmm I
don't know let's blend
yeah Charlie you're actually supposed to
beat this off butter and sugar until
thoroughly combined and somewhat
lightened in color then you're supposed
to add eggs one at a time mixing until
just adore and then you are supposed to
stir one third of the baking mix in
stirring to half the milk I'm not a SUP
another third of the baking mix the
remaining milk then the remaining Nick's
okay well it's clearly not fitting here
well I know you're you just read the
ingredients down the line also why does
that makes it like whoa would you have
to mix it that way
whoa
Oh God the one thing it's so powerful
that if you let go it'll just move away
I think yeah that looks like a pretty
similar to step number five in the
directions clearly we know what we're
doing yeah yeah we go baking what's a
greasy live
he doesn't say so I would assume you
could bribe then you get it's a little
political joke I don't get it you know
you have to like in especially like
corrupt countries you might have like
grease the local politicians so yeah
that was a really good joke people
thumbs up okay so yeah so but it doesn't
specify so presumably you can grease it
with any damn breathing device you are
actually pretty good yeah do you think
like maybe put too much listen xanthan
gum
Oh what just recipes taste on the
gluten-free all-purpose baking mix
gluten-free flour
okay this changes everything go back to
the cake direction go numb put some
weight or good chefs a little bit that's
a lot of well actually just pour this in
we should at least start pouring yeah oh
my gosh this is I don't think this is
gonna be very good just based on its
looking pouring quality this looks like
glue it serves a similar purpose
yeah you know I've got some unrest and
questions about this case we should have
followed the Dirks questioning what its
gonna look like though
it's hot so we'll see you guys in a few
minutes so we do the first test yeah I
hate to cut this conversation short so
it's what we've done we've black Katyn
is being burnt okay hold on a second
it's like I think it's rising see here's
the problem we've been discussing this
off-camera that it smells like pasta it
does not smell like the cake I feel like
it smells like sandwich bread yeah so we
are going to attempt to make the cake
look like the book cover like a cake
should not do that it's rubber
it's it is plastic it's yeah just the
cake yeah no I think this is a lot of
red well that's like Dexter yes this
looks so Dexter like this could be like
part of like the intro of Dexter where
it's like it starts in really close and
you think it's something gross and yeah
it's out really oh it's just cake batter
drum bowl
I thought about it but like you know
yeah I'm gonna get a bowl you know the
red food going is made from my beetles
yeah I read about that
yeah not vegan yeah I'll make sure to
get a great shot of yeah hmm that's
great this is a mixture you should not
eat this look at this red food dye
sounds good
do you know I on the carpet how did none
of this get on the carpet none of it get
on my phone how it looks like we've a
massacre yeah sting more more deaths to
it there's like I feel there's three
drops three drops oh yeah yes some luck
you lucked out maybe a spoon great idea
things I've also not good at logic more
read a little more I'll just use the
whole thing yeah why not the entire
thing is why not I'll get some paper
towels your inabilities that is so red
if anybody eats that they will
immediately probably poop themselves oh
you're just kind of just put on like
just put it put it right in the middle
number right in the middle yeah just put
it all just go home yeah why not like
icing the cake ratio it's pretty awesome
and by awesome I mean about as much
icing as we have cake yeah okay here we
go let's just even us out let's go
inside the crow boss here think I'm
gonna buy some scissors like I have them
but I mean do you have some upstairs or
some you know I just don't like I think
I threw them away
i but such a few possessions of this I'm
taking every stuff from the bottom what
do you think of that yeah it's not on
the box on your here yeah yeah so that's
a lesson I've learned from this is that
Drake Drake it only got some drink with
it's a real Drake saying yeah I'm so
good at this
it completely destroyed this cake so it
can't get any worse
I saw a faith that we're gonna go put
this in Barnes & Noble I'm doing a
little mistake it for the book
I'm surprised like you didn't do this
for the book I sleep recover make the
cake and then take a picture of the cake
and then well then oh that is what we
did
mm-hmm we just had like a better
confectioner cake balls than you and I
sorry guys still aren't cake is complete
and I just tried to take a picture with
it and I held it up and it's already
it's like sliding out yeah it's uh but
look at that look at the color scheme
just I mean yeah
pop quiz right in the comments left or
right which one is the book and which
one is the cake you'll probably get it
wrong I mean if we put that book in a
pan a cool honestech like which it is
look yeah yeah my god which one is which
you don't know so we're gonna try it
this has an entire container of red food
dye also the question is which which
word do you want I'm just gonna dig okay
so
it's hard it is surprisingly hard to
four caliphs like I'm not getting any
cake well this is enough no I hope
you're not allergic to food I yeah let's
hope not cuz this is what like this is
no my merrily food ugh he's kind of like
cookie like I think the the icing is a
little overwhelming yeah mmm the cake is
a little underwhelming recipe that we
followed or did not follow us yet just
the two recipes that we followed neither
of so yeah that's it thank you guys so
much for watching make sure you check
out josh's book and his youtube channel
anything else you want to tell them look
where they should get the book tell them
about the book yeah we should hang out
sometime calm you can find out where you
can find the book the book is about how
I never had a girlfriend and I was like
in my mid-20s and I investigated why I
had never had a girlfriend by
interviewing all the girls who'd
rejected me awesome
not awkward at all it's a great book and
thank him Justine read it it's Justine
approved and uh yeah I read it as well
and my mom said that she just finished
reading it and she loved it as well so
relaying the message yes I mom approved
yes and also check out my channel where
I will have an interview with Justine
about her upcoming book so that's gonna
be awesome
oh goodness okay bye we should hang out
I'm not hmm oh my this is too much red
food yes so much so much food dye nice
humid start yeah